so I'd always heard about the design
school prior to coming to the business
school and then I would see my first
year of business well friends come back
from across the street as we like to
refer to this glow and kind of
excitement in their eyes so I feel that
my thinking was kind of very focused
towards being very rational and
analytical in everything I do so I kind
of wanted a different perspective on
things the bootcamp class at the
d.school is the kind of introduction to
our way of thinking it teaches students
how to have creative confidence around
our methodology we call Design Thinking
it teaches them to be empathetic teaches
them how to have impact on the world I
think I'm a creative person but since I
was like 5 or 6 years old I've learned
to be more structured and structured and
structured which got me even with like a
superstructure job and a superstructure
career path so I feel like I'm learning
how to combine structure with creativity
because sometimes the freedom to explore
your ideas can take you somewhere that
structure simply can't and in fact can
be more powerful and added in to like
what you're trying to achieve I really
want something I can take on the real
world and to be able to work with real
partners just gonna made that won't
happen anymore version then you get to
your first project mention just the
depth of your insights that's what
really changes at least within this
process needs among max out your
creativity
but you also need is they focus on the
front
because I'm thinking is the kind of
thing you have to do you know have to
experience you have to have that moment
where you're on a project and you come
up with much better more creative ideas
than you thought were possible being in
the Design School space and kind of
being around boundless creativity and
everyone's an entrepreneur kind of
mentality made me think that maybe I
would do something more entrepreneurial
doesn't have that kind of confidence to
feel like that would be okay maybe this
is like a PhD student thing like we
think a lot and then like have a lot of
different ideas but never really like
try them out I think the biggest thing
that I learned was that we really need
to bias towards action I very very much
value being able to work alone but this
class showed me how much stronger a
project can be if you have multiple
viewpoints coming in and actually on the
entire process going forward I probably
will be more willing to collaborate in
much deeper ways I've let go of some of
my fears the will to admit failure to
build up the courage sin and failure I
think that's that's really something
that you know a lot of people need to
learn being okay with failing being okay
with failing so that you can move on you
can make more progress instead of kind
of getting stuck at a dead-end
I don't know if it's something like that
like it's just like contagious like just
like you never stop seeing opportunity
now you just think there'll be
possibilities everywhere